now let me tell you about EMDR highly  recommended by Dr Raymond as well and  also my I mean for me I had tried this  with my therapist yes I have a therapist  I actually plan to almost always have a  therapist because the work should always  be on yourself like you can't change  someone else you can only change  yourself so that's my word of wisdom of  therapy and we did EMDR and it was like  time travel time travel there's also  another book I'm pointing because my  bookshelf is over there the body keeps  the score and it's a super heady book  and it's like got a lot of dense  information but one of the prevailing  therapies for healing everything from  PTSD to depression and all kinds of  different emotional states is EMDR  because it is like time travel and when  I heard EMDR for the first time I  thought what's EMDR do you is this like  a do you take something is it like you  hook up to something it sounds intense  right but it's it's not actually